what's been absolutely blown up across
social media across normal media across
just about everything online is this
paper the first room temperature ambient
pressure superconductor that sounds big
it sounds big and indeed the final line
they don't pull any punches the final
line of the entire paper we believe that
our new development would be a brand new
historical event that opens a new era
for humankind amazing right
absolutely amazing
except it's really been shot down that
this was published on the 22nd of July
2023 a couple of weeks later it's been
absolutely pilloried online shot down
from a number of different angles and I
could go through the science but there's
so many videos out there that cut
through the settings I guess the
briefest and the the neatest and
pithiest deconstruction of the Sciences
Sabina hasenfelders uh she goes through
it in about five minutes and really cuts
into pieces and I'll talk a little bit
about the science but what I really want
to get across is this is not how to do
science this is really frustrating for
the rest of us you know if you think you
get a result you get a groundbreaking
result like this I mean if we had room
temperature superconductors
are they going to help with certain
things yes are they really going to
revolutionize Humanity perhaps not will
they give us more efficient power
um transfer will they give us more
efficient uh levitating Trends yes all
that types of things but are they
absolutely going to rewrite the rules
possibly possibly not so the paper
claims that they have discovered are
superconductor that works not just at
room temperature but at temperatures all
the way up to about 120 degrees C
which is frankly quite amazing because
we've known about superconductivity for
about a century now and initially up
until about the 80s we had low
temperatures superconductors where the
the What's called the critical
temperature the temperature at which the
superconductivity just gives out and
we're back to a normal metal normal
um type of electrical conduction
of the order of a few Kelvin few degrees
above absolute zero to a few tens of
Kelvin maybe then there was a huge
amount of excitement in the 80s with the
discovery of what are called high
temperature superconductors now that's a
bit of a misnomer because high
temperature to a physicist is not high
temperature to everybody else in that
these were superconductors that would
work at liquid nitrogen temperatures and
all those demonstrations you've seen of
um magnets and stuff levator or
superconductors levitating above magnets
and little trains going around Etc all
of that and you see the the
um the condensation due to the liquid
nitrogen in the background or sort of
steaming officers where that's those are
all high temperature superconductors and
there's been a drive obviously can we
push this further can we keep going both
for the the the pure intellectual
excitement of it all but also of course
well you know the wear would be a pretty
important application because the
superconductor implies
this is patientness implies a current
flowing with no energy losses which is
really quite amazing and it's really
complicated really fascinating physics
physics and it involves for the
conventional superconductors it involves
how the electrons couple to how that
good crystal is wobbling and how they
pair up into these things called Cooper
Pairs and then for the high temperature
superconductors it took a long long time
it was really only last year where
there's been good definitive evidence
for a particular mechanism of pairing up
those electrons in high temperature
superconductor conductors
um has really got got a lot of
supporting evidence due to uh work of a
group a led by a guy called Sheamus
Davis uh fellow Irishman so this paper
what were they what magic bullet did
they claim they'd found they basically
argue that effectively they stumbled
upon this fortuitously this mixture of a
lead containing compound and a copper
containing compound they mix them
together and as if by Magic somehow
superconductivity uh appears and they
have got these very strong statements as
you've just heard in terms of this is
going to change the world we have
discovered even the title of the paper
not the way to do science even I get
emails sometimes from people saying
they've had some great invention or a
great discovery and I take them with a
grain of salt
but this one has been widely reported
everyone's been talking about it so
there must be some reason this is
getting more credence
it's interesting it's intriguing because
when you look at that there was this
paper and then there was a follow-up
paper which was uploaded exactly the
same day and I don't understand why it's
getting traded so there were some you
know there was obviously a lot of people
out there who were quite skeptical but I
don't know why the kickback wasn't
stronger because this
this is not the way to present data so
this is the resistivity as a function of
temperature is that is that your
addition there the W yeah the WTF is my
Edition that's not in the original paper
I can give you a censored redacted
version if you want pretty but so here
first of all if you've got a
superconductor you hit that critical
temperature and the resistivity drops
and it stays flat that's not what's
happening here it you can see even on
this diagram it it drops okay there's a
jump but there are many other reasons
you can have a jump in connectivity and
then it sort of tails off so they are
claiming the superconductivity just on
the basis of this moreover and even more
perplexing is this resistivity scale so
resistivity is just the resistance per
sort of unit cross-sectional area per
unit length that's all it is so it's the
resistance taken into account the
dimensions of the sample effectively
and it's 10 to the minus 2 ohm
centimeter I can pick up a first year
textbook this is our first year physics
textbook let's look up what we'd expect
for normal metal what type of
resistivities okay its own meter so we
have to add uh instead of one centimeter
we have to take off a factor of 10 to
the minus 2 here so we've got something
like 2.8 by 10 to the minus 6. so even
so and on this scale this is 10 to the
minus 2.
you can see this is 1 by 10 to the minus
2 2 by 10 to the minus 2. if you really
want to show that you've got something
which has got the resist the resistivity
has dropped as close to zero as you can
measure you do not present it like this
you zoom in on this area and you show
well actually this is far below the type
of resistivity we expect from metal so
just that graph alone I can point to
many other things and maybe we'll do a
little bit of that but I just don't get
it and there are even people saying that
the interesting thing there was a very
widely
um publicized or very widely shared
essentially viral tweet which was why
are scientists not getting more excited
about this and the problem is you're
training as a scientist is not to get
excited particularly if you discover
something in the lab your first job is
to go it's wrong where is it wrong where
have I effed up how do I fix this then
you go back and you check again and then
what you don't do is put this on the web
saying that this is this brand new
um Dawn for for Humanity
and without
I would argue let's share this in terms
of the peer review process let's get
some feedback on this I would say it's
really Brave slash arrogant to just put
it out there and clear make these claims
on the basis of this type of evidence
who are these people though because
anyone can say I'm changing Humanity was
this some reputable group at Cambridge
like surely it's a Korean group with
very very little if any background in
superconductivity which again is why are
people jumping all over this and what
frustrates me is is really we've
discussed this many times before billion
we're both very keen and sort of opening
up the scientific process and letting
people in but the problem is when when
claims like this are made and then
they're shot down
we have this trickle effect where the
credibility of science keeps getting
eroded and it's very frustrating I'm all
for letting the cameras in but let's do
the science properly so this hasn't been
peer reviewed and published in a journal
no
absolutely you know it's just on the
archive which is what's called a
pre-print server where it's a good thing
to upload stuff to the archive that's
before publication we've discussed the
issues with peer review before some
really dodgy papers get through peer
review I'm not suggesting but with this
you know it doesn't take a lot of peer
review and I'm not an expert in
superconductivity I do condense model
physics we play with big magnets etc etc
but I'm certainly not an expert but even
to those who aren't expert in the field
you look at this and you go well if this
was an undergraduate experiment and
undergraduates often measure
superconductivity
in a range of different samples as
projects you'd go well no this clearly
is wrong zoom in here have a bit more
evidence instead of having just one
point in this transition maybe measure a
few more points that type of thing so it
just looks and feels sloppy so what's
the point of the archive then if people
can't put their preliminary results on
there before they get published in
journals good point that's a really good
point so I'm sort of it's a little bit
of a dilemma for me
um should the archive be there
absolutely I've argued argued strongly
in favor of the archive before
the problem is one of the downsides of
the archive particularly in the social
media enabled age is that something like
this can go on which has had absolutely
no quality control and I can just apart
from the the the very small level of
moderation associated with putting a a
paper in the archive and
if you're getting lots of papers to
moderate you're getting lots of papers
to consider you can't give every
particular paper
a great deal of attention so things can
slip through the net but the problem is
when it blows up like it did whereas I
said I tweeted 30 million views
every newspaper Outlet every media
Outlet every social media outlet has
jumped on this saying this is the future
of humanity
the problem is we need some level of
quality control what should they have
done oh so they should have repeated
this measurement with a wide range of
different samples they should ensure
that if they want to convince people
that basically until this resistivity
drops and stairs dropped you don't go
ahead and say this is a room temperature
superconductor you just don't because
that's the key piece of evidence is for
that resistivity to drop and stay flat
it tails off the whole way down and then
eventually whatever this is close to
room temperature is zero but the problem
is zero on this scale means nothing
because this could be 10 to the minus
six very easily 10 to the minus six
which is just the same as the
resistivity here
the other aspect of it is they have the
sort of other part of the um or The
Smoking Gun as it were in terms of
superconductivity is this thing called
the meissner effect where you have your
superconductor
um uh will uh uh essentially reject a
magnetic field and so you can have a
superconductor and a magnet at above it
and the magnet will will levitate but
is is levitation has just fallen off
fantastic
this is just a piece of bog standard
graphite carbon we're going to put it on
top of magnets which are arranged so
we've got a nice little minimum in the
magnetic field in the center here I'm
going to drop it down that's levitating
that's just diamagnetism that's that's
that's nothing to do with
superconductivity
it's just the fact that some materials
and graphite turns out to be a really
um uh good at doing this reject a
magnetic field repel a magnetic field
other materials which are called
paramagnetics are attracted to a
magnetic field and then we have Ferro
magnets when you know that you've got um
like your enormous Ridge magnet but this
is just routine diam magnetism at room
temperature so one of the other pieces
of evidence as it were is that they've
got this rather dodgy lump of
superconductor
um which they they claim is is
levitating above a magnet and it's sort
of halfway down and halfway up now there
are a couple of things that could
explain that without super conductivity
first of all it could be strong
diamagnetism or indeed it could be
ferromagnetism where you've got sort of
North Pole here south pole here you're
above a magnet North Pole is attracting
to South Pole but South poles are
repelling so it does that and indeed a
couple of groups have claimed that where
does it stand now has it been would you
say this has been debunked or it's the
yeah I would say it's been sorry sorry
to put in but yeah I would say it's been
wholly debunked and um which is in that
sense
is science working it's you know it has
worked uh within two weeks or whatever
three weeks two and a bit weeks of it
being uploaded it's been debunked I
would say thoroughly but the problem is
is the sort of remnant of it that exists
out there in the social and the way it's
raised expectations and then in this age
of bloody misinformation where
scientists are you know criticized and
not trusted tough stuff going out there
like this which claims so much and it to
be so sloppy it's it's very frustrating
there's no chance they've got this right
and you're going to look silly in a year
if they've got it right I'm very happy
to eat Humble Pie you can bring it in
and I'll eat my Underpants I'll eat your
underpants whatever I'll eat there
underground
um you could be eating a lot of uniforms
very very happy to be um proven wrong
but I very much doubted have you ever
published something that's been wrong
yeah later yeah thank you or what a
great question yeah so we had to retract
the paper and you don't want to retract
a paper
um it's it's embarrassing it's
frustrating and it was my fault I cocked
up a calibration we used we've talked
about this before we use these Teensy
tiny tuning Forks uh to measure into
Atomic forces but we have to calibrate
the response of those tuning folks I
know if we put a certain voltage in how
much the The Tuning Fork is moving and I
screwed it up and I screwed it up by
about 50 not a small amount which meant
that we basically had to pull a paper
it's out there you can find it's there's
a pub here which is post-publication
peer review thing and there's there's um
the retraction notice as well it's very
frustrating
um and very embarrassing but that's the
way you have to do it if you see
something wrong you have to to retract
it indeed the president of Stanford has
had to resign recently for exactly that
reason that there were papers that were
out there to his knowledge were wrong
and he didn't retract them and this is
president of Stanford so we have to keep
science clean we have to keep it as
close to the truth as possible so and
the other thing that worries me in some
other fields
mistakes like that and
misinterpretations of data aren't
treated the same so a while back there
was this Fury at um CERN all this
excitement about a sort of new peak in
the data where there was 400 500
Publications on this it was a noise it
was a statistical blip and I would say
that you retract those papers
in that particular field however they
would claim well if it's moved Theory
forward
even if it's wrong what's the problem
and I would say as an experimental
condensed matter physicist
you need this it's absolutely essential
to have this feedback loop between
experiment and theory and if that's
broken science is broken
so you can see tips resonating tuning
Forks resonating
we bring it in on top of an atom
hopefully people who you would think
could do a very good job at looking for
your paper criticizing it critiquing it